we have the story from NBC News peaky
blinders and Cillian Murphy denounce
homophobic video shared by DeSantis
campaign the video uses footage from
various films shows in mediality to
depict the Florida governor taking
extreme
anti-lgbtq positions and we have this
tweet it says on behalf of the partners
of peaky blinders Stephen Knight Cillian
Murphy Karen mandebok Productions tiger
aspect Productions and bana J writes we
confirm the footage of Tommy Shelby's
character used within the video posted
by Rhonda sent us a campaign was
obtained without permission or official
license we did not support nor endorse
the video's narrative and strongly
disapprove of the use of the content in
this manner and then we also have this
from the hill Republican lgbtq group
blast DeSantis over homophobic campaign
video I don't know if they actually post
it but you guys might remember this we
talked about it last week
I thought it was cringe I don't know did
you see this video man I saw it where
it's like Trump with the LG with the
pride flag and he's and saying you know
like we're gonna protect our lgbtq
supporter or LGBT supporters and then it
starts showing all these news clippings
of Ron DeSantis you know rejecting a lot
of the more modern woke stuff my take on
it was it's absurd to conflate Donald
Trump saying the the typical or the more
traditional Live and Let Live position
with the modern woke grooming position
like Trump is not supporting grooming
and the stuff that Santa is going after
now that we support is stopping the
exploitation of children to conflate
those two things to make it seem like
Trump supported grooming today is
completely wrong but it's resulted in a
major backlash what I'm seeing on
Twitter this has been happening for for
the past week or so we've been out and
now even peaky blinders coming out and
attacking him over it I'm not surprised
the media and Hollywood or whatever
would come after him but even
conservatives are criticizing him for
this you know uh I sort of put on my
political consultant hat with this one
and this is just one other case of
desantis's Staff screwing up his chances
oh yeah and this it's no it wasn't Ronda
stance that went to the account and
retweet it no look outside groups create
edgy weird videos to support their
candidate all the time and that's what
happened here some edgy outside group
created this but then somebody who has
access to the campaign account saw that
and they thought oh let's let's retweet
this one because then it made something
it was an outside group that had
distance from the campaign maybe maybe
it got a few voters their way or made
people ask questions how committed is
Trump to the anti-groomer agenda and
then they totally stepped in it by reach
and basically by retweet they took
ownership of the video and look I run in
the same circles of people that work for
DeSantis and all the other campaigns and
inside the complaints about his staff
screwing up his campaign have been
persistent and growing louder going back
months and months and here's the problem
is that you when you're a governor of a
state and you you win a seat by a large
margin because you're a great Governor
she is and your candidate your opponent
is terrible everybody in the staff that
thinks they're the ones that earned you
that 19 Point Victory and in terms of
expanding from a governor's race to a
national race which is from t-ball to to
Major League Baseball
you have to expand that Circle of trust
and what he's done is he's taken a team
that didn't really do a lot to get him
through a governor's race and now oh now
we're running a presidential campaign
and that he has to learn to expand his
circle of trust to get people who are
not going to allow bonehead mistakes
like that to happen and because look
this there's a lot of stuff going on
there's been
tremendously detrimental to his campaign
and it just comes down to staff and I
look it's his it's his steps his his
campaign press team
have been rolling around in it like
crazy picking fights with a women's
group in New Hampshire because they
dealt with they double schedule an event
New Hampshire with the most powerful
women Republican women's group in the
state everyone's saying oh we're sorry
we'll uh move it to a different date or
a different time or something like they
said oh we'll pick a fight with these
guys what kind of fight what'd they do
public a public fight like verbal on
Twitter yeah like that kind of fight
which it's just there and there's stuff
happening behind the scenes I can't
really see share them aware of but I'll
give you one really good example okay
so there's this guy this congressman
from Florida who us uh Greg stube who uh
was not sure who he was going to endorse
he had to endorse Trump yet like most of
his colleagues from Florida right and uh
he's up in the air right and he had he
got a phone call
a member of desantis's Staff called him
to say hey can you hold off endorsing
president Trump because we'd like to get
your endorsement
both of you know the problem with that
right
a staff member calling a member of
Congress to back not the governor a
staff member this is a guy this is
interesting because this guy he had an
accident he fell off a ladder in
December or something he badly injured
himself the first person to call him in
the emergency room Trump yes and I've
got so many friends who are like Mitch
they're like mid to clear low tier
influencers say something cool about
President Trump guess what they get a
FedEx with the Tweet with his signature
on it say keep up the great work yeah
like all candidates have their flaws but
it it's just really troubling to see
these repeated mistakes and Trump's team
they're all on top of some things you
know they're they're great at these
Trump is the guy I saw I I went to his
rallies in 2015 and 16. when the rally
was over he'd walk up to the the front
of the stage the barricades and he would
just hang out and shake hands and just
talk to whoever was there he knows
people
calling that guy if they're getting hurt
he's like a person it's like authentic
thing to do DeSantis has been plastic
the whole time he's surrounded his press
people are miserably bad and I want to
show you this real quick uh so put it
put a pin and I thought Phil predict it
now has Ron at 24 cents he was actually
rivaling Trump and at some point if he
was above Trump now he's he's gone
it's it's just gone Matt do you think
that because as far as I can tell the
the strategy that the Santa's has is to
attack Trump from the right do you think
that that's a
a winning strategy
I'm not sure that that is his strategy I
think it's been different things at
different times which is part of the
part of the problem look it was going to
be an uphill battle to begin with and
I think it was a little bit unexpected
was that the indictments would actually
and first I could see this I'm sure
everyone at this table could see this
but the indictments were actually very
helpful to consolidating the base to
Trump and they did something else is
they sucked all the oxygen out of the
air for all the other candidates right
plus with the fact that you've got all
these other candidates coming in if it
was a monomy model it might be a
different story because I think what
DeSantis value proposition is that I'm
just as conservative not more
conservative but I can actually deliver
on what I say because they'll point out
to you know things that Trump couldn't
quite get done do you feel like Trump's
because I feel like Trump's strength
wasn't in that he was particularly
conservative his strength was that he
would take the fight to the left so
Trump didn't have to be like you know he
was he was friendly to LGBT uh issues
and stuff like that um and he didn't
really come from the conservative
especially the religious conservative I
mean everybody remembers the whole you
know the Bible is my favorite book of
the Bible you know that that exchange so
I don't feel like he was ever
particularly far to the right did you
feel like he was it I think that there
are issues where he was to the right of
the party on immigration he was by far
the most right-wing candidate in 2016
because
right before he went down that elevator
escalator he had read Ann coulter's book
on immigration and that fired him up and
that really put him on the map and uh
but I think the what he has over the
other candidates is that he's a known
quality a lot of people think he was uh
is it the election in 2020 was rigged or
I I can say it now I guess some people a
lot of people think it was stolen or
rigged and uh you could always say that
but you just couldn't play Trump saying
oh yeah yeah but he um he is authentic
and he's got a level of authenticity
that is like when you read his tweets
when he was on Twitter and now his
tweets are still on Twitter because
they'll just take truth and repost it on
Twitter you read that and you know he
wrote it and you know nobody nobody's
got in his way it wasn't focus group or
anything like that
whereas some of these other candidates
they I think they just struggle a little
bit with the authenticity it's kind of
crazy watching uh
DeSantis is crashing and burning and it
really is his press team because he has
done great work this uh this video I
pulled it up here's the video from
DeSantis war room to wrap up pride month
let's hear from the politician who did
more than any other Republican to
celebrate it and they insult Trump for
what actually was good I know a lot of
people are not happy with the pride flag
and the current woke stuff but we've had
this conversation for years nine million
Obama voters switched to to the
Republican party and one of the big
issues was
Donald Trump was very much like these
are our Americans we're going to support
them this battle is over there is a big
difference between being like hey we
have no issue with you if you're gay and
there are people grooming children and
putting these weird books in schools
DeSantis is fighting against those weird
books he's fighting against the grooming
stuff really really great work Donald
Trump was not in support of those things
back then the completely different
issues they're conflating them DeSantis
goes from you know on paper you have
this amazing track record in Florida to
a press team that is making him look
ridiculous I mean this video I said it
was cringe people were like I really
like it here let me play a little bit of
it for you guys
everything in my power to protect our
lgbtq citizens but Caitlyn Jenner would
walk into Trump Tower and want to use
the bathroom you would be fine with her
using any bathroom she choose that is
correct in the future can transgender
women compete in this universe yes make
America great again
okay it's basically showing
American Psycho and peaky blinders and
showing ad headlines like Rhonda Sanders
signs Draconian anti-trans bathroom
build the law and
it this is really just not doing him any
favors like you were mentioning
attacking him from the right what is the
purpose of this video is it like so I'm
37 this video doesn't do it for me I'll
tell you because in 1996 there were a
lot of people outside the Trump campaign
that were creating really cool videos I
do this all the time my wife's yelling
at the TV right now
my golden times yeah in 2016. they were
creating these really cool third-party
videos that were like the meme Wars
right yep like the caterpillar uh videos
and they're really kind of cool and they
had a style they're trying to imitate
that and capture that whoever created
this video I'm clearly they've got some
editing talent and they're trying it's
in a it's got this motif of like a sort
of a 4chan pole Motif and vibe to it and
you almost think if you slow it down
enough you might see one of those um
there's sort of a white nationalist
Stars those things wrote I can't
remember what it's called the Golden Sun
thing rotating in the back of the black
sun it's black sun it's like of that and
I feel like whoever created it was like
we're trying to get to these guys and
maybe they're not the most Savvy right
but somebody hit the retweet but button
on that campaign account and that is
that is uh they they can't they don't
belong to that job anymore we just find
out one person who needs to be fired
from the campaign were they fired from
this we probably wouldn't even know and
maybe they will be maybe they won't so
that that obviously has also had the
Deep fake thing when he posted the fake
photos of trump and fauci and it's still
up it's still up it's remarkable that
DeSantis I'm sorry
look man
I love his track record in Florida but
the man is incompetent if he cannot fire
his people after all of these blunders
the dude is not fit to be president yeah
and it's like it's fine like if you
wanted to actually if the campaign
wanted to get a video like this out
there to us to undermine uh Trump among
say a certain portion of the right you
have like an outside group just sort of
put it up like it was original like some
weird thing that they circulated through
the discords and the telegrams where
those people uh where those people live
and don't touch grass
but that there's you know and there's a
reason you know oftentimes you want to
have an indirect attack so you have it
somebody far away throw it at them and
then your hands are clean right this is
on an operational level a failure like
why didn't you psyop which is crazy
because you don't want candidates to be
psyopping each other but I mean he
didn't sigh up he put it on the DeSantis
account it was made by somebody else and
then they took the URL to the video and
tweeted it sorry to interrupt you were
saying yeah yeah but I mean maybe the
campaign did create it and they want to
get it out too but you don't you do
these things like I said I've been in
this field since the mid 90s that's why
I keep saying 96.
this is oh this is old school political
operation you have somebody else attack
you have some other source go after them
a distant proxy so you keep your hands
clean and they just Dove face first into
the mud with this one
look
a lot of people keep defending Ron they
say things like this is his campaign
it's not him blah blah blah at this
point the man has not taken the tweets
down or fired these people okay that
right there we talk about the problems
of bureaucracy these you know what I
love about the DeSantis people on
Twitter is they lie about what I've said
and if they're gonna play that game
where the Santa's post deep fakes then
they lie about what I'm saying they're
just trying to trick you into support as
a guy for whatever reason I don't know
one person was like Tim Poole thinks has
said that Trump will magically be
different this time around I was like I
never said that I said there's like a 55
chance Trump actually fires a bunch of
these people and that's the best we can
hope for if the probability between uh
if the probability is higher that Trump
will fire the bureaucrats over to
sandusk you vote for Trump
DeSantis won't even fire his own bad
staff members and we're supposed to
believe he's gonna end the Department of
Education or the IRS or something get
out of here with that not going to
happen in his defense that would cost
you with one thing and that is that it's
a long way to Iowa to New Hampshire to
South Carolina and a lot of these
candidates can make their course
Corrections you never know what's going
to happen next
um I'm begging him
I am helping him I like his track record
in Florida I mean we we had on uh I'm
not going to say the names of these
people because they're duplicitous Liars
but we had a guest on culture War show
who tried to play in this game of like
name a Polish from descent policy from
DeSantis and no matter what I said she
just kept asking the same question as if
I didn't say anything because of course
they were clip farming and they intended
to lie the whole time but the sentences
policies based in Florida how he handled
kovid was good when it comes to the
books that they're being removed from
these schools good when it comes to
saying you can't have kids at these
events good these are good things
clearly in terms of culture War issues
we care about he is doing a good job
when it comes to attracting business and
new residents when it comes to taxes
he's doing a great job don't get me
wrong the Republican legislature in
Florida is probably doing a lot of the
heavy lifting but we like these things
because they matter to us
then when it comes to his terrible team
he can't handle it I am begging that a
Santa's campaign to fire these people so
that I can come out tomorrow and say I'm
on team DeSantis you know before not
gonna happen unless he does yeah and the
thing is too I've been all over the
country I've met with a lot of people
who we need to win over a lot of them
they or they would be more happy to vote
for DeSantis than for Trump at this
point in time they would be they they're
they're you know for some reason they
just don't get along with Trump and I
think that look I actually met the
governor before he started running for
president I had a small chat with him
just one-on-one and he was great and I
think that he wrote a book recently it
was published right and uh the courage
to be free I think and I read it I went
from beginning to end and it was a nice
book good biography but I don't think
enough of him was in it like he talked
about his whole baseball career right he
played baseball in high school and
college was very proud but I feel like
he needed to be more there's something
wrong with the book because it never
told me what position he played so
imagine talking about how proud of your
first question to play baseball but the
book and maybe I missed it however ever
before he ever ran for congress after he
got out of the Navy he actually wrote a
book that I am sure he had to have
written himself because he didn't have a
bunch of people around him helping it
was uh dreams of our founding fathers
there were only 100 or so copies
published I got one of them made a copy
of it myself and I started reading
because I want to know these guys the
difference between those two books the
one that came out recently that was
probably had many editors and a lot of
help and the one he had to have written
himself that he he self-published 120
copies of he would go to GOP events and
sell it at a card table that book is
brilliant that book is it could be a
textbook in a college it is that level
of understanding of our founding fathers
the principles of how articulate it is I
just I'd love to see more of the Ron
stance that wrote that book then the new
one but if he is so weak that he has
handed off these issues to lesser uh
skilled individuals than he has shown he
does not have what it takes to be
president he can he can have great
policy all he wants but just like you
know just like Tim says if you can't get
get elected if you can't then it doesn't
execution is everything it's not just
about getting elected it's about if he's
showing us that he has bad people
working in his campaign and he does
nothing about it what do you think is
going to happen when he's in government
he should be I mean he is in a position
where if he were if he were doing a
better job uh you know
um campaigning he should have you know a
significantly smaller gap between him
and Trump Trump's got a lot of downside
you know regardless of whether you you
support him or not there's a lot of
things people can criticize Trump for
Trump hired some bad people yeah he
definitely did but Trump has no problem
smack talking the people that he
eventually got rid of DeSantis is just
doing nothing and saying nothing
that's right you know what would be the
real sign to everybody that he's he's
going to make a course prediction
he calls you and says I want to come on
your show because when you're in the
position he is right now you need to be
here you need to be talking to this
audience you need to be engaging and
that's up to the people who watch this
show right you know uh I'm just some
dude who complains about things on the
internet uh I I don't I I you know it's
like you know we've had people say like
Timmy should get Trump on you should get
this person on and I'm like dude none of
these people owe me anything if they
want to come on the show I'd love to
have them if Ron wanted to come on the
show we'd love to have them we wanted to
have them before and I think a
conversation like this but it would
greatly benefit him but here's the point
I think what we're seeing is that he is
incapable of a long-form free-flowing
conversation in this way he is too
surrounded by bad people who are not
allowing him to be an authentic
personality like Trump is I I disagree I
think he's capable of it if he just
undoes the tie and does the black collar
comes in and just sits down and Deals
because he's I know he has it in him
they just have to come in and don't
disagree what I'm what I'm saying is the
people who surround him are not allowing
him to do these things yeah we should
shoot some hoops come on down Ron let's
go play basketball on the skate park for
a little while and a couple hours before
the show get loose and then I don't know
if the man has time for that that could
be that all the Time in the World Turns
The Campaign around and then he does he
reaches out he has this type of
conversation which I know he's capable
of and then his poll numbers go but I
believe the environment and fixing Earth
and stuff whether whether it is this
show or any other show if Ronda Santos
came out and sat down and had a real
conversation where they addressed the
Deep fakes where they talked about uh
this ad his his polling would Skyrocket
double digits overnight overnight his
predicted would jump way up but he's
avoiding it hoping to make it all go
away like it's 1993 and we're using old
school PR tactics of if you say nothing
it goes away yeah take a look at Bud
Light dude people aren't forgetting
these things they're taking them
seriously and you know president Trump
has demonstrated that you can put people
in positions of great power
and then fire them and talk them
endlessly thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time